we will have a discussion on the  Commission opinions on the Italian DBP  we are not to take any decisions today  Italy was requested a revision of its  DBP and we are looking forward to heat  hoping that Italy is able to take steps  in order to take the DBP in line with  our fiscal rules we will be debriefed on  the recent stress tests on our banks we  all know that challenges remain despite  a very strong effort that we made in  reforming and constructing the banking  Union and to help us in this debate I am  very glad that we invited Nobel Prize  laureate Jean T hall to help us in the  discussion we also have another  discussion on the reform of the banking  Union today's novelty is that we will  have a discussion on european common  deposit insurance this is for sure going  to be a lively discussion which will  take us hopefully a step further to take  decisions on December